[Music]
how can one become so bounded by choices
that somebody
else makes adele had hearts wide open as
she debuted three new songs from her
album 30 during the cbs special adele
one night only this is a new song i
haven't sung this song yet for anyone
not in real life
myself the song triss performed at the
griffith observatory in front of a
star-studded crowd which included lizzo
kris jenner ellen degeneres
and drake to name a few
[Music]
in addition to performing her single
easy on me for the first time in front
of a live audience adele opened up about
the efforts that go into making a
relationship work with the debut of i
drink wine
[Applause]
[Music]
if that one touched a soft spot take a
listen to hold on a song that reflects
some of adele's darkest hours
[Music]
i swear to god i am
such a mess
the heart that i try i regress
i
[Music]
the 33 year old closed the show with
another song off her new album love is a
game
[Music]
[Music]
ironically playing games in love is
something the 33 year old says she's
over i don't treat it like a game
anymore you know that thing of like
you're going to hurt me so i'm going to
hurt you first i certainly i'm not like
that anymore the special also included
an intimate sit-down conversation with
adele and oprah in oprah's rose garden
adele gave intimate details about how
her divorce from simon kaneki after
about a year of marriage in eight years
together inspired 30. is this the
divorce album
i think i'm divorcing myself on it yeah
yeah how does one do that
so it's lonely you know i spent a lot of
time on my own
really sitting in my feelings and not
keeping myself busy leading up to
adele's big night oprah's bestie gail
king opened up to e.t about her reaction
to their sit-down just the two of them
together was really nice and it was very
intimate and very i wasn't there i
wasn't there i just heard from reliable
sources that it was really it was a very
special day i think for both of them
actually they had never met each other
before
i know i thought that too
i thought that too kevin when she said
adele and i've never met i go what do
you mean you've never met they've never
met they had never met
so she arrived oprah went to go greet
her
she saw what adele was wearing and she
thought
i think i'm going to change into
something else
really
okay great they look great when you see
the two of them together you'll
understand and she was already wearing
something fabulous but when you see the
two of them together you'll know why she
made the choice that she made